en cela le sénat a été précurseur
mon gouvernement partage avec vous bon
nombre de priorités et même sans aucun
doute de solutions dans certains
domaines et pour certains textes au delà
de ce que la constitution prévoit le
travail parlementaire pourra commencer
dans cet hémicycle avant de se prolonger
à l'assemblée nationale
ainsi le sénat pourra pleinement agir
comme force de co-construction au
service des territoires et des français
[Applaudissements]
répondre au message des français cela
veut dire associés et donner la parole à
tous mon gouvernement consultera les
corps intermédiaires les forces vives de
notre pays nous mènerons chaque réforme
en lien avec les partenaires sociaux
nous serons à l'écouté de tous nos
compatriotes de leurs aspirations et de
leurs idées nous agirons surtout en lien
étroit avec les élus locaux
les élus locaux sont les premiers
interlocuteurs des français et les
meilleurs connaisseurs de leur
territoire ils sont les visages du
courage et de l'engagement ils sont en
première ligne face à toutes les
urgences ils sont les premiers
innovateur bien souvent précurseur pour
les mobilités pour la transition
écologique
la crise sanitaire nous l'a montré une
fois de plus pour aider nos concitoyens
ils étaient présents pour la campagne de
vaccination ils étaient présents pour
expliquer alerté accompagnés ils étaient
présents je veux rendre hommage aux élus
locaux pour chaque projet mon
gouvernement les associera les écoutera
pour chaque défi nous nous inspirons de
leurs idées et de leurs actions ils
doivent avoir de la visibilité de la
stabilité il n'y aura pas de grand
bouleversement dans les compétences des
collectivités
ils doivent avoir les moyens d'agir nous
définirons avec eux un agenda
territoriales en cherchant un accord sur
des objectifs et des moyens notamment
financiers
ils doivent avoir du poids le conseiller
territorial peut être l'occasion d'une
complémentarité plus forte entre
départements et régions
sur ce sujet
sur ce sujet nous lancerons des
concertations approfondies l'année
prochaine
surtout les élus locaux et plus
largement les territoires doivent
pouvoir prendre les décisions adaptées
au contexte local
je le crois fermement répondre au
message des français se lassent cela
passe par des solutions au plus près du
terrain les cinq dernières années ont
été l'occasion de premier pas nous avons
entamé le retour des services publics
partout dans notre pays
plus de 2000 maisons france services ont
vu le jour notre objectif est simple pas
un français avec une maison france
services à plus de 30 minutes de chez
lui nous avons avancé dans le
déploiement de notre couverture mobile
et haut débit nous avons investi pour
faire revenir la vie et l'activité dans
les centres villes et les bourgs nous
avons donné aux collectivités les moyens
de solutions différenciées je veux dire
ici un mot de la corse le cycle des
discussions engagées avec les élus et
les forces vives sera relancé dans les
prochains jours il doit aboutir à des
solutions concrètes pour tous les corses
et notamment la jeunesse des solutions
concrètes pour le travail pour le
logement pour la transition écologique
pour le développement économique et la
sécurité
nous sommes prêts à ouvrir tous les
sujets y compris institutionnels allait
discuter en transparence dans un esprit
constructif et responsable mais ne
cédons pas à la facilité
répondons au cas par cas à ceux qui
bloquent dysfonctionne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
veux vous proposer une méthode d'action
pour les années qui viennent il est
temps de rendre son sens au mot égalité
trop longtemps nous avons cru qu'il
signifiait qu'une règle unique dictée
depuis paris devait s'appliquer partout
toujours et sans adaptation possible
l'égalité réelle ce n'est pas un carcan
c'est nous fixer des ambitions communes
et trouver des solutions adaptées pour
les atteindre car mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs qui peut réellement
affirmer que les enjeux de santé sont
les mêmes dans le centre de lyon où dans
les banlieue de pointe à pitre qui peut
réellement penser que les écoliers des
quartiers nord de marseille font face
aux mêmes défis que ceux des villages du
calvados bien sûr il ya des enjeux
communs mais la justice territoriale ce
sont des solutions différenciées mais la
cohésion des territoires ce sont des
marges de manoeuvre donné pour la santé
pour l'éducation pour la transition
écologique pour la ruralité pour la
ville nous associerons les élus les
habitants des associations
avec eux nous dresserons des constats
avec eux nous trouverons des solutions
avec eux nous donnerons des moyens
je souhaite ici avoir un mot particulier
pour nos compatriotes d outre mer il y a
quelques jours l'appel de fort de france
a été un nouveau signal d'alarmé les
outre mer c'est une jeunesse prête à
s'engager
les outre mer ce sont des trésors de
biodiversité
les outre-mer ce sont les places fortes
de notre souveraineté grâce aux
outre-mer le drapeau tricolore flotte
partout dans le monde alors dans les
outre-mers la promesse républicaine doit
être tenues avec les collectivités nous
agirons pour la présence des services
publics contre la vie chère pour le
développement économique et l'emploi
contre la délinquance et l'immigration
illégale
ce quinquennat sera également l'occasion
d'une nouvelle étape dans notre histoire
républicaine avec la nouvelle calédonie
j'y prendrai toute ma part
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
confiance en nous et je suis déterminé
je sais la volonté constante du sénat de
bâtir au service de la france et d'agir
au service des territoires
des français
[Musique]